what does science have to say about
motivation yes uh there are a couple
things to say about motivation one is
motivation itself is technically in the
construct of adherence is just one of
the parts of it there's inspiration
there's motivation there's habit there
is um interaction between sort of
willpower and all that uh goggin
which is super valid in context and then
there's something called passion which
once you have a passion for something
you no longer ask questions of
motivation like people ask me like what
motivates you to go to the gym like I
addicted to going to the jet like asking
a crackhead like what what's motivating
you to do that light up that rock what
that's what I want to do right so there
is a whole Rich psychology around just
the one part we call
motivation but that richness actually
informs a lot of the things that it's a
good idea to employ to increase your
motivation we're really trying to
increase this adherence trying to make
you get to the gym make sure you get in
there how you get in there doesn't much
matter so one is having good sources of
inspir Iration if you surround your
social media if your feed is a lot of
people who look like you kind of want to
look a little bit like them and they've
got a lot of positive and encouraging
to say and a can do attitude that's
a good start now it's not going to keep
you in the gym but it might get your ass
in there on a rainy day another
thing is to set goals motivation is in
many senses defined as the pull towards
a goal you get rid of a goal you're
technically not motivated to do
like animals in a lab are motivated
goal- based at least neurochemically you
could have hubman on here I'll tell it
to you better is like motivation is is
goal oriented even if the goal is
equalize this amount of chemical between
one brain cell and another so if you
have a goal of like I want XYZ amount of
reps on my lifts that's realistic or
even um a motivation like I want to be
able to tell myself I'm mad enough to go
to the gym four times a week every
day this year that's my goal a
process goal instead of an outcome goal
that's a big deal if you're goalless if
you're going to the gym for some very
general construct like get fit or have
abs or something you haven't really
Quantified in any way at all or really
contextualized it's easy to be like eh
it's like you have to be able to answer
the question in your head of if you're
sitting like you got home after work
tough day at the job you sit down on
your couch you have to give yourself a
reason to get up if your reason is
nebulous and like I think Fitness is
something I told myself I do you're not
getting up when push comes to shove
your that beer and you're done
but if you're like I told myself
contract with myself I'm going to
make it 4 times a week awesome
there's another part of this motivation
thing that comes in with how easy are
you making it on yourself you don't want
to have a big barrier to entry training
Partners help a lot you sit down on the
couch and your training partner
texts you and he's like where you at
you're probably gonna show
up if it's just you it's G to be tougher
if your gym is 15 minutes away you'll
do this in California traffic
for 15 minutes if it's 45 minutes away
holy that makes it really tough
another thing is doing the kind of stuff
at the gym you like that's where the
favorite exercises comes in if you
can't wait to smash some
deadlifts hey by all means that
optimal go in there and get you
some deadlift so there's a lot of stuff
coming together another thing I will say
this is just my own little spin
on it this is a much richer conversation
we could have in great
depth I want to put this in a way that's
both charitable and sufficiently comedic
to be expressive
if you have to
ask how to get motivated to go to the
gym you don't need to be going to the
gym you don't want it enough when you're
sick and tired of looking and feeling
like you'll show up
I'll see you there because you're going
to look in the mirror and you're going
to be like that you're going to
want to be in the gym and if you're
going to make this a lifestyle you have
to lower the barriers make the gym
cheaper closer training Partners
exercises you like and you have to raise
the impetus goals inspiration and a
godamn real desire to be there
the people that have no problem showing
up to the gym are the people that want
to be there and no amount of Rocky baloa
movies are going to get you to
that place a lot of that is also built
with the experience of having the gym be
a place where you get results by pushing
yourself winning little mini challenges
and having fun with it when I think
about what does the gym mean to me I
still remember what it meant to me when
I was 15 and first walked in it was a
Scary Place full of scary people that
had scary things going on and I was bad
at them I didn't want to be there after
25 years of training the gym is my
spirit home anywhere I go I could be
anywhere in the world one thing I like
to do is I come into a gym let's say I'm
traveling and go to Thailand or some
like that after enough lady boys
you got to hit the gym you're not even
strong enough to lift them up anyway uh
so I come into the gym and I I I've been
doing this for for a generation I grab
grab a barbell and I just cinch in like
a deadlift grip it's some kind of
Spirit connection I belong in
the gym because to me the clanking and
the groaning and the smells and the
machines they are experiential symbols
of progress of Love of passion mechanism
yes of a good time so one thing is get
yourself into the gym however you see
fit consistently have a good
time there doing what you love push
yourself get those little mini victories
RP hypertrophy apps as you're doing a
little better over time and let that
fill you up uh let that grow on you and
then after a while also it feels great
especially after the workout you like
after a really solid leg workout someone
could punch you in the face You' be like
ah that was pretty sweet Dolphins see
you next time buddy that's it you don't
give a that stress relief every
you're driving home after the gym hard
day at work blah blah blah you're like
thankful for it's it's like a post
mushroom trip Clarity every single time
and it's good for your health it's just
all these massive green chalk
boxes all around you get into that habit
and that's the big part of habit you get
in the habit of doing the gym and it's
all this hurricane of positive
influences and reinforcement you're not
going anywhere 3 days after not being in
the gym like you know your
mother-in-law drags the family to like
some cabin in Northern
California it's just us having fun as a
family no gym after 3 days you're like
you guys this is going to turn into some
mans and I don't get the out
of here you're at the local gym doing
this and then everything is again so
getting up to the point don't push
yourself so hard that you hate the gym
remember it's all voluntary it's all for
fun it's a Leisure activity I have a PhD
and a Leisure activity someone
with PhD and bowling is equally amount
of social value probably more so it's
all good start start easy get to the gym
twice a week maybe three times 30 minute
workouts 45 minute get some progress
going get into the Habit make it easy on
yourself once you're in the habit for
long enough you can start to crank up
the intensity and you're going to want
to be there and you never have to ask
yourself the question again of what
motivates you to go to the gym because
the answer is it's where I want to be
what else didn't we cover in
troubleshooting what are the other big
ones yeah um have you been to our
earlier conversation purposefully
progressing in loads of reps you haven't
been pushing yourself what the is
wrong with you like one of those guys
that you mentioned like he's doing the
18 kilogram dumbbells all the time have
you tried the 20s have you tried doing
more reps so uh making sure that person
is kind of gun to the Head treating it
as a thing another one is where are you
on the balance of recovery uh versus un
under recovery versus over recovery if
you ask someone like oh man my legs
haven't grown okay how hard are
you training your legs like pretty
hard how long do they get sore
for like what I just don't don't get
sore anymore I got sore for the first
couple months of training
anyone training legs properly properly
is just going to be sore from when they
finish the leg workout or a few hours
later until the day before their next
leg workout unless it's a deal week in
perpetuity if you train intelligently
definitely something I think that people
get used to which is this uh
conditioning to training where
you you only are s after the Christmas
break yes you only are s after the D Lo
week yes and then your backround and
it's like oh yeah you know like weeks 4
through eight I I'm fine I'm just like
I'm just recovered ask yourself to the
person who is in that position ask
yourself the philosophical question of
is what doing
I've answered that in the affirmative
long
ago uh I tried the whole mirror thing
where I looked in the mirror and I'm
like you're
a power bottom still oh yeah well that I
earned um ask yourself a philosophical
question if you're used to some and
it's no longer experientially
challenging for you are you really so
sure you're growing your best overload
is a principle in training but it
transfers into psychology as well your
body's pretty good at detecting
what's challenging for you if you're
psychologically pushing yourself to the
limits quite often you can rest assured
you're probably working hard enough if
you've been used to some for months
and you're wondering why it's not
growing you why the would it grow
you the body generally likes to resist
being changed in many ways because in
our evolved ancestral environment we're
very resource constrained you don't want
to piss away tons of resource for
hypertrophy you have to continually
challenge yourself so if someone's like
well yeah I'm like recover is not a
problem I'm going to be like try
training harder try training more if
they say dude I basically can't recover
I'm going to say pull back so it's two
different answers based on how you're
doing it it's like it's like if you're
uh helping someone with your area one of
your many areas of expertise which is I
assume talking to women for the
eventuality of getting them to do fun
things with you if a guy's like
basically saying nothing and he comes up
to you he's like what did I wrong you're
like you got to talk but if
he's you got to rise it up but if he
sits there like me and he's like she's
like you're like I'm going cut you off
let me keep going you're like come here
you have to talk l same with the
recovery thing pluses and minuses um I
already mentioned the nutrition the food
thing sleep is huge I I'll put it very
very simply for sleep I could talk a lot
more about sleep and all the
technicalities I'll say it this way if
you are chronically underslept I
actually don't need to hear about your
program or your diet I don't give a
because it's all just downhill it's like
telling me about how awesome your new
fighter plane is but I'm like what kind
of fuel are you using you're like I
we're supposed to put fuel in it I'm
like the out of my face you have to
sleep it's critical it's the Cornerstone
of everything how do you know you need
enough you're not getting enough sleep
if you can't stay awake throughout your
day without like a medical dose of
caffeine you need to sleep more could be
nine hours for you consistently could be
six Ronnie Coleman apparently slept five
or six hours a night more or less his
whole life looks recovered to me you
know uh huge genetic differences there
in sleep requisite but you have to be
getting enough sleep so enough sleep
enough food the training has to be
sufficiently hard and you have to
recover and then everything else is
details you could play with rep ranges
frequencies so on and so forth that's a
troubleshooting list that's available on
our YouTube channel there's like an hour
long but those are kind of the
big pictures that I want to talk to
people about in other news this episode
is brought to you by a product I've used
every single day for over three years
now and that's ag1 Dr Andrew hubman and
Tim Ferris and Dr Peter AER and Joe
Rogan all use ag1 because it is the best
all-in-one foundational nutrition
supplement on the market they've
upgraded the recipe 52 times times over
the last decade as new research has come
in and as they've improved the
ingredients and it really works I tried
pretty much everything on the planet and
this is the best you don't need a
handful of pills or potions simply one
convenient and tasty daily drink that
has everything that you need so if
you're looking to make an upgrade to
your nutrition this is the place to
start best of all there is a 90-day
money back guarantee so you can buy it
and try it every single day for 3 months
and if you don't like it at the end of
that 3 months they'll give you your
money back head to drink a1.com
wisdom to get a Year's free Supply
vitamin D3 and five free travel packs
plus that 90-day money back guarantee
that's drink AG
1.com wisdom that's drink a1.com
wisdom thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that clip with Mike you
will love the fulllength podcast which
you can get right here go
on press it